die tsg hoffenheim empfängt den fc
bayern julian nagelsmann tritt wieder
mit voller offensivpower an natürlich
auch mit robert lewandowski der seinen
eigenen tor rekord knapp über eine halbe
stunde gespielt die zuschauer sehen ein
gutes offensives spiel in dem die
kraichgauer in führung gehen christoph
baumgartner nach der flanke von david
raum es ist bereits dessen zehnte assist
in dieser saison
kurz vor der pause in der nachspielzeit
der nachspielzeit gleicht robert
lewandowski aus saisontor nummer 29
unter der woche traf er in der champions
league ja schon drei mal gegen salzburg
in hälfte zwei kommen die bayern zu
riesigen möglichkeiten erst leroy sany
dann sehr knapp und
schließlich noch thomas müller aber mit
etwas glück und oliver baumann im tor
erhält hoffenheim das eins zu eins der
keeper der mann des spiels
es war eine knappe partie im signal
iduna park aber was soll's hauptsache
gewonnen werden sich die dortmund fans
denken bielefeld hielt stark dagegen
doch der bvb setzt sich dank des
treffers von mario wolf mit 1 0 durch 21
10 minute schöne hereingabe
zweites saisontor für den dortmunder
dann diese aufreger nach einer halben
stunde für das handspiel von robin hack
gibt schiedsrichter bastian dankert erst
elfmeter doch dann nimmt er ihn nach
ansicht der bilder wieder zurück in
hälfte zwei fast das 2 0 für den bvb
daniel malen scheitert haarscharf an der
latte
63 minute darauf haben die fans lange
gewartet comeback von giovanni rana und
erling holen aber ein tor fällt nicht
mehr dortmund gewinnt mit 1 0 und
pirscht sich an die bayern
tolle atmosphäre vor dem spiel zwischen
bayer leverkusen und dem ersten fc köln
aber es wurde sehr schnell zu einem
richtig späteren nachmittag für das
heimteam doppeltes verletzungspech bei
der werkself erstes foul von kainz an
frempong nach 13 minuten bereits muss
der leverkusen heraus und es wird noch
schlimmer keine halbe stunde gespielt
florian würz verletzt sich am knie
diagnose kreuzbandriss er muss vom platz
getragen werden und wird lange ausfallen
nach 64 minuten wechselt köln judith und
schindler kommen drei minuten später
flanke lulic in der zentrale steht ganz
genau kingsley schindler das null zu
eins gleichzeitig der endstand perfekter
doppelwechsel von steffen baumgart
leverkusen verliert zwei spieler und die
partie schlechter hätte es nicht laufen
können
gladbach gegen die hertha eine partie
bei der man zuerst über die trainer
reden muss christian peintinger ersetzt
den cupid infizierten adi hütter der iss
während der 90 minuten nicht da dafür
hat er nach dem spiel seinen job noch
bei tayfun korkut verhält sich die
sachlage genau andersrum 24 minute foul
von kämpfern tyrann elfmeter für
gladbach fan klar die führung saisontor
nummer 6 für den franzosen
nach knapp einer stunde erhöhte mathias
ginter auf 2 0 für gladbach ein ganz
wichtiger befreiungsschlag
herthas beste chance durch ecken kam
landet an der latte die berliner
kassierten die fünfte niederlage in
serie
zu viel für den trainer am sonntag wurde
tayfun korkut beurlaubt bis saisonende
übernimmt felix magath
freiburg gegen wolfsburg und wenn sie
christian streich so sehen dann können
sie sich schon denken was hier los war
gleich zu beginn ein schmankerl 17
minute vincenzo grifo traumtor zur
führung
kurz vor der pause wieder der italiener
sein zweiter treffer nicht weniger schön
er ist einfach ein überragender
techniker zwei zu null aber die gäste
kommen zurück maxime arnold auf max
kruse der anschlusstreffer und der
auftakt zur aufholjagd
84 minute
schlotterbeck kriegt den ball nicht raus
dann kommt arnold und haut ihn rein aus
208 2 zu 2 aber jetzt das highlight der
partie nico schlotterbeck 87 10 minute
der siegtreffer ein tor schöner als das
andere
und jetzt ist auch jeden tag warum
streicht so ausgeflippt
ähnlich wie dieser kollege denn der vfb
stuttgart holt sich in letzter minute
einen punkt bei union berlin danach
hatte es lange nicht ausgesehen
wegen des handspiels von marokkos gibt
es elfmeter für die eisernen 41 minute
toni verwandelt sicher saisontor nummer
ist der vfb arbeitet kämpft gibt nicht
auf und wird letztlich belohnt sascha
karadzic mit dem ausgleich in der 90
minute eine super flanke von boller sosa
und ein ganz wichtiger zähler für die
stuttgarter im abstiegskampf
eintracht frankfurt gedenkt der
verstorbenen vereinslegende jürgen
grabowski dem weltmeister von
1974 im spiel gegen die gäste aus bochum
in führung freistoßtor die liebe ist
kopfball folter so einfach kann es gehen
das null zu eins nach 19 minuten
kurz nach anpfiff der zweiten hälfte die
eintrag schafft den ausgleich durch ein
eigentor von erhan masovic dem feld eher
unglücklich ab keine chance für manuel
riemann im turm knapp fünf minuten
später dreht frankfurt das spiel die
kamera da steht goldrichtig und schiebt
den ball ohne probleme ein das 221 die
eintracht gewinnt nach rückstand noch
die partie da macht auch attila große
augen
das letzte spiel am sonntagabend ist
gleichzeitig das torreichste führt gegen
leipzig und das kleeblatt hat nur einmal
grund zur freude der minute die führung
für den tabellenletzten durch jenny
nebeling doch dann geht's dahin allein
in hälfte eins trifft rb viermal das
erste tor für die gäste durch andrej
silva 17 minute dann geht es schlag auf
schlag emil forsberg dreht das spiel mit
einem starken fernschuss 1
223 minuten später konrad laimer setzt
einen drauf das nächste tor und sekunden
vor der pause trifft benjamin henrichs
zum eins zu vier jetzt wird's bitter für
für die zweite hälfte leipzig liegt nach
mohammed sina.com mit seinem ersten
saisontor ein artistischer treffer des
franzosen den schlusspunkt selbst
christoph höhnke in der 69 minute das 1
zu 6 die gäste spielen entfesselt
aufführt geht im eigenen stadion unter
die ergebnisse des 26 spieltag der fc
bayern lässt in sinsheim punkte liegen
leverkusen verliert zu hause gegen köln
borussia dortmund damit der große
gewinner der top 3 das spiel zwischen
augsburg und mainz wurde wegen zu vieler
corona fälle verschoben und so wirkt
sich das auf die tabelle aus der bvb
noch sieben punkte hinter den münchnern
aber mit einem spiel weniger leipzig und
freiburg klettern auf den
internationalen plätzen nach oben der
vfb stuttgart verlässt die direkten
abstiegsränge und tauscht mit hertha bsc
die berliner auf platz 17 felix magath
soll jetzt also für den klassenerhalt
sorgen
[Musik]